[Music]
welcome back to fox and friends texas
governor abbott issuing a new executive
order
restricting transportation of migrants
who may be at risk of spreading
coronavirus
now attorney general merrick garland is
threatening texas with legal action
in a letter to the governor writing the
order is both dangerous and
unlawful it violates federal law in
numerous respects and texas cannot
lawfully
enforce the executive order is this
setting a double standard for covet
precautions well we're going to ask host
of justice
with janine uh justice with judging
judge janine pirro
always such an honor to be on with you
judge um
so tell me what you think of this this
seems like a pretty mild
thing to say hey maybe we shouldn't let
illegals with covet go through texas
this is the classic showdown between the
state and the federal government
as as well as the fact that you've got
the biden administration that is laying
down the welcome mat for illegals
they are literally transporting them and
this pretty much rose out of the fact
that they've got covet infected illegals
they're laying down the biden
administration the welcome mat
taking them through a non-government
organization catholic charities
to a hotel they're covet infected they
don't have a court date
they don't have a medical appointment
they don't have supervision
they leave the hotel and then they end
up going to a restaurant where they're
coughing and sneezing and everybody down
there in texas
is saying what is going on so the
governor of texas has a very good
uh argument that he is in charge of
protecting the health and safety of the
citizens
of texas he's not trying to enforce the
immigration laws
what he's trying to do is prevent
covet-infected people
from infecting the members of his state
right and of course this is something
that you would think the biden
administration given that they want to
mask up american citizens
would at least be understanding about
and still the ag says this
is dangerous for governor abbott to do
that it's crazy
this is crazy town yeah it's completely
crazy
and i get it you know i'm not i'm not a
legal expert like you but i get it the
feds are in charge of immigration
um and our border but what i don't
understand is
liberals had no problem defying the feds
when they wanted sanctuary cities
i look at texas again mild order from
from the governor
why doesn't texas just do more i mean if
any state in the country judge
could just say we're going to do this i
mean texas thinks they're their own
country practically
why can't they just do more
well why can't texas do more i mean
because the federal government
wants illegals in the in the country
and that's what this is all about if
they have to stop a governor from
performing his lawful duty
of protecting the health and safety of
his citizens
and you know it is evident that they're
not interested
in the reality the data dr sapphire just
talked about it
you know then the the end game here is
to make sure that we're under
that we have to wear masks masking
people in congress it's crazy
this is absolutely crazy we're going to
talk about it this weekend on my show
i'm doing an investigation of the delta
variant
i'm also talking about the fact that
what parents need to know
by a high-ranking dea official of how
much danger their kids are in
with fentanyl crossing the border a lot
of it made in china
this is a takedown of america and we're
letting it happen well that's what the
biden administration is
well justice with janine is always must
see tv especially this week thanks for
joining us judge
thank you